boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host on saki on we
are still on site in Boston
Massachusetts we are actually in
Cambridge at MIT the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology we are at the
Media Lab right now and we are going to
be talking about all things genetic
engineering we are going to be talking a
lot about biology we're gonna be talking
a lot about these different nuances of
what's gonna be happening going into our
future I'm super excited to be talking
um to pronom chatterjee who is a he's a
graduate student here at MIT Media Lab
pursuing his PhD in Media Arts and
Sciences pronom Chatterjee thank you so
much for coming on the show tonight
thank you for having me really
appreciate it it's had to be here super
pumped / Nam's awesome he's like a he's
like the second generation of taking the
CRISPR technology and exploring it and
moving forward with it and discovering
new things with it and he's also really
good communicator he's teaching a class
right now about genetic engineering and
and I'm really excited to talk with him
about all this different stuff so
pranaam let's let's start with you know
let's start with who you are um so how
did you first even realize that you know
you know where you were born how did you
start finding your interests inside you
tell us about that so I mean I grew up
in like the I was born in Florida but I
grew up in the kind of the middle of
Georgia suburbs of Atlanta and so like
that really framed a lot of my
upbringing right my dad was a scientist
my mom was a scientist so they were
really they kind of instilled within us
that mentality I have a twin sister as
well who goes to MIT so my whole family
is this really scientific kind of like
eclectic family growing up you know in
in America where that we're second were
immigrants my parents are immigrants my
sister and her first-generation
Americans and so with that background
you know we were able to explore a lot
of stuff obviously you know
as a cool part of our upbringing but you
know at first I was really interested in
a lot of different things and one thing
that was really cool about Georgia and
living in I would say like the Bible
Belt of sort was to was to interact with
people have a very very different
mindset than you do you know like
everyone down there is pretty much you
know a very strong religious probably
very Christian you know and so growing
up I was very interested in like just
how people thought you know the
different worldviews like what was the
best way to understand how the world
works and that got me through you know
different different studies different
fields of thought I I know it's kind of
funny but I spent a lot of my time
growing up reading a lot of religious
texts just to get to know people around
me you know like the Bible the Quran the
the the Torah you know like I spent a
summer to Buddhist monastery
you know like religion was really
interesting to me my parents were super
religious at the same time and so it was
cool for me to see how that world view
right the world view of you know related
from a religious studies background
could inform how people saw the world
but at the same time approached the
world in a more in a rational
perspective that's kind of what has led
me to Who I am today
yeah so as as you say that I'm thinking
about all of the different ways that
people pick up religion when they're
really young and then they slowly sort
of start to kind of realize that it's
all about the feeling of like
spiritually kind of transcending oneself
and and the ego and more so about this
collective unity with infinity and the
cosmos and etc and and and this is so as
I think as we're as we move forward
actually let's let's jump back into
because you started picking up theology
you had two scientific parents yeah yeah
it's kind of weird and I know why I like
even jumped into that was because it was
such a like major player in my life not
because I'm particularly religious my
parents were like I said but but you
know like the really the one the fun
thing about it is that science
to me and to what I thought was one way
of accumulating knowledge about the
world like how did it work what is the
best way of like understanding the
evidence around us
well religion was you know another way
of thinking and and and and that's why
when I went to college for the first
time I went to Dartmouth College for my
first two years of undergrad I wanted to
study this you know I spent a lot of
time reading texts as I said I then
spent a lot of time going to like
monasteries churches synagogues learning
about this and then like what are the
next obvious step you know while
appreciating all the other feels the
obvious next step for me was the study
do religious studies in college so it's
very different than what we're talking
about here today I like talking about
genetic engineering so but I actually
majored in religious studies at
Dartmouth College for two years um I
actually concentrated in East Asian
religions know like you know that
Buddhism like you said like really
things that are very different than what
I do now and later realized that the the
world the way I wanted to view the world
was through reality how things have
worked the kind of mechanisms why they
work and and
the nature of evidence was super super
exciting to me therefore I'm here now I
transferred to MIT from Dartmouth where
I now study and where I studied computer
science and molecular biology and you
know the rest is history I guess so I
want us to really realize why computer
science and molecular biology is such a
crucially interesting pairing yeah
because the could with code with you
know with code in zeros and ones in
binary and then with AST CS and G's the
DNA bases that there is such an eerie
similarity in being able to understand
biochemical pathways exactly and that's
I think a new way of approaching biology
I know biologists obviously been a
discipline that's you know has its way
of own way of doing things for many
years and you realize that if you're
going to come in and be a major player
like actually make a contribution to it
you need to be able to think in a new
way in a different way maybe even an
advanced way like so that you can really
push the boundaries of the field you're
in and you know I realize this that when
you're going into biology or going into
any field you want to do something that
people care about that people think are
cool and will have a transformative
effect on what humanity is gonna be so I
said really the two things that we'll do
that are AI artificial intelligence we
all know how that works and we all know
how that's really pervading all these
different fields but also gene editing
right like and just like molecular
biology the tools that biotechnology is
giving us you know it's changing how you
know just curing diseases it's changing
agriculture shading bioenergy it's
affecting a lot of fields and so if you
can not only forget merge the two fields
you can really create the synergistic
effect that allows you to push forth you
know research discoveries that people
care about people really I think are
excited about what we're doing here in
the lab and I hope it seems that way
yeah I'm happy that you really
identified that that but that
biotechnology is is going in to
everything as well as artificial
intelligence really it's so interesting
how
it's kind of like is like the secondary
like AI is of course there's a lot of
overlap right the fields the biotech is
just going into so many different places
from the food that we to the way that we
treat our own diseases and ailments and
prevent them as well okay so so it's it
so even though you made the transition
to MIT and you figured out you wanted to
do computer science and molecular
biology
what from there got you to the genetic
engineering specifically and CRISPR
right yeah you know it's not it wasn't
with you right like it's not me just
jumping in from theology directly into
CRISPR gene any future right like it's
not that easy I think really what made
it so cool was that I was able to you
know stay in a field that was also
really interesting in the last 5-10
years in some in terms of scientific
research and that's the field of
immunotherapy right immunology of sort
so I actually spent most of my undergrad
even while at religion major my over the
summers and through the school year I'd
work in a research lab studying this one
molecule and that was called the
molecule of pd-1 so I don't know if you
know what pd-1 is but it's actually a
really what we call a very hot
immunotherapy marker meaning that it's a
molecule that is easily targetable if we
target it you know we have the ability
to you know affect a lot of different
things that are happening in your body
especially when it comes to diseases
like cancer for example out I'll just
make it really brief but pd-1 is on the
surface of our immune cells right and if
we're able to bind to a PD one if a cell
another cell is able to bind to PD one
it can actually turn off the immune
system it'll turn off those immune cells
they can't you know protect your body
like you know em you
you know your immune system does and
this is what a cancer cell tries and
that's exactly right you guessed if you
took it
Ken's the out of cancer cells playbook
they literally will bind to t-cells
prevent them from being able to attack
the tumor cells so in the tumor
environment
these cells are turned off and so a lot
of what I did as an undergrad was first
understand how this happened the
pathways within the t-cell that allowed
them to get shut down
so I one of my major papers I published
with my lab as an undergrad was
understanding the metabolic pathways
within the t-cells that have this you
know PD one shut down occurring and that
way we were able to identify what are
the important features of this molecule
that made it so special and then the big
the big you know biotech Pharma
interests came into this field just like
maybe about five 10 years ago like right
like in the kind of like in the middle
of my undergrad people started realizing
hey if we do something with this
molecule you know this this could be a
really great treatment and so I don't
know if you've heard of the new drugs
called cheat ruda and opdivo they came
out of merck and bristol-myers Squibb I
was working at Pfizer over the summer
where we were working on antibodies for
pd1 you know if you can prevent the pd-1
antibody from being ligated you can keep
those immune cells on and that's what
that antibody did and so now we're you
know able to you know go after a disease
like melanoma blood cancers like
lymphoma leukemia in patients that have
pd-1 and they exhibit pretty amazing
results as a result of this treatment
yeah interesting so the first foray was
into immunotherapy yes and then
specifically to make sure that that
immune cells were able to hold to cancer
cells couldn't block that pd-1 receptor
immune cells could continue hunting
exactly for the cancer cells properly
identifying them and killing
and killing them and that's powerful
right because this is not like standard
cancer therapies that are you know very
invasive
they're not like chemo therapies I can
kill healthy cells they're not like
radiation therapy that can you know
oblate large portions of like again your
your say the immune system your healthy
immune cells so this was a targeted
treatment for these patients and there
it's now two of the most I would say the
most prescribed cancer drugs for our
patients with these tumors specifically
yes that's also so crucial that rather
than doing this full body nuke yeah then
it's a targeted molecule that comes in
and goes straight for exactly anyone
exactly and I think I think that is you
know a movement going forward one is
still a pretty amazing field it's like
how can we use you know what we call
these and to blocking antibodies to to
affect the immune system so that you
stay as healthy and active and your your
body stays as healthy and active as
possible always looking out for anything
that could go wrong it's a very powerful
approach and I hope it's something that
you know continues to drive the field of
therapeutics going forward yup yeah and
you were doing this with Harvard Medical
School and Pfizer
and then you come to do the graduate
work yeah so I was like had to make a
decision I think at that time who
realized that you know immunotherapy had
really reached its peak right like this
is we've discovered the set of new
molecules like antibodies that help
treat it now you know really what is the
next great you know thing that will you
know like bio technological tool that
will take us into the future and clearly
that was CRISPR you know gene editing in
general because you know guess what when
you can edit genes you can edit you know
you can affect feels like agriculture
you can affect bioenergy you can affect
you know the ecosystem simply by editing
living organisms and the DNA that makes
them up and so I realized that you know
if we're if you're gonna really make a
you know big splash and you're gonna
train on top of this you want to do it
in a field that matters and I think
CRISPR is a super cool field and I'm not
I wasn't the one of the first people to
do it but I'm lucky
right now a reoccurring theme that I'm
seeing from pranaam here is that he is
going to the edge of what's known like
the edge of immunotherapy then he's
trying to you know which a spurt off
nice yeah I'm for two for curing
melanoma and blood cancers lymphoma etc
and then you know for working on that
and then there's a new edge and that
edge is the overall edge in genetic
engineering exactly and and you want to
be there we talk about that a lot is
striving to get out of the base camp of
knowledge where a majority of people are
yeah it kind of just day to days and
aiming to go to the boundary of human
knowledge yeah and I'm glad that you
have that as this powerful like I want
to know what's going on I won't know
what's going on genetic engineering want
to be out there I want to be studying it
I want to be teaching it be advancing it
and you have already been a huge part of
advanced yet
wait and that's you know that's a
motivation I want to like you're you
know you have a lot of different
responsibilities as a scientist even as
a person who like went to MIT I feel MIT
is cool because you're really thought to
think outside the box you know we're the
Media Lab of all places where I'm not
even in a standard bioengineering
program or biology program we're in a
place where you can literally go and
answer whatever questions you think are
interesting you know my professor is one
of those people eyes name is Joe
Jacobson you may have heard of him he's
the guy who invented the the Kindle
technology the e-ink so he's and guess
where we are now we're doing CRISPR so
like the fact is that it's cool to move
from field to field always staying at
the edge like you know we can we design
tools that you know will help us to take
these for example gene editing into the
future so that more people can use it
more people can use it safely and it can
go to a lot more places and that was my
motivation yeah huge shout-out to the
Media Lab because the when you come to
the Boston area you have to come to the
Media Lab and come and look at all the
different fields that the Media Lab is
exploring at MIT this is this is what
the cutting edge is they are in so many
ways exploring that cutting edge and Joe
Jacobson exactly Joe Jacobson shoutout
as well
okay so let's actually talk about where
were so we had a discovery about five
six years ago yep of crisper cast nine
accelerating our ability to do genetic
engineering yep
making it very easy to target making it
very easy to make the genetic edits we
need inside of specific genes that we're
looking at cells that we're looking at
zactly so then now we're kind of
following there's like a big wave that's
coming after that and it's this wave of
people like you that are like really
understanding how can we make this
better how can we make it more right
active yeah yeah we I mean first of all
like many shoutouts to they've got the
guys who really may discover this thing
it's it's amazing CRISPR is not
something that we invented it's
something we discovered but to be able
to repurpose a system that was
originally an immune system for bacteria
bacteria into a gene editing tool for it
to go into humans into plants into
animals is amazing
first of all so shout out to all like
the people came before me in this field
and shout out to bacteria bacteria
nature that made this amazing system
three and a half billion years evolution
of evolution which is why bacteria has
so many of these different ways of
protecting themselves making them so
that we you know like bacteria can
protect themselves as so elegant of a
fashion you know we can definitely see
how can that be used in an elegant
manner so that it can be used to treat
diseases or or you know you for
agricultural purposes whatever and so
you know as the second generation of
CRISPR scientists as he said said before
my job are my interests lie in really
not just tinkering with it but kind of
revolutionising the technology to us
first of all today is safer right so we
can make sure that this technology
doesn't do what we don't want it to do
and secondly give the ability to go and
make the changes you want to make don't
be limited by what the regular CRISPR
system has the limitations it has and so
you know at the early stage of our you
know research in CRISPR in our lab you
know
me and a few other grad students in the
lab Noah shoutout to know I got a shout
out it's all a team effort you know we
do it together it's right but you know
like what we really did focused on first
is making it safe because if you don't
make the system safe you're not going to
be able to apply it in all these
different settings and one of the things
that really is kind of dangerous and
like you really want to avoid is
something we call off target effects you
know if what if you just say you have a
gene or a specific target sequence that
you want to go to but there again
there's another sequence somewhere else
in a different gene that is very similar
maybe one or two base DNA bases off
that's not very much different sometimes
the original CRISPR system will go to
the correct location which is supposed
to go to but also go to the wrong gene
go to the wrong location and that's what
we call an off target effect and it's
very important that we figure out
solutions to make sure that that doesn't
happen because once you go into a
clinical trial you don't want to accent
a hit the gene that codes for brain
function or a heart function or anything
like that you want to just edit the gene
that has the mutation the the change the
abnormality and make the change and be
done with it and so that's what we
focused on what we would be built was a
system that essentially destabilized the
CRISPR system in general at the wrong
site but kept it stable
on the right side so when it's stable it
can do what it needs to do it can target
the spot it can make the Edit if it goes
to the wrong spot you don't want it to
do it and that's what our system did you
made you destabilize it when it was at
the wrong
caresse and people have tried to do it
before there are ways to do it where you
could take the enzyme and you could you
know reduce the charge of the enzyme so
it doesn't bind the DNA as strongly and
then destabilize the DNA so that it only
binds strongly when it's at the correct
site but not when it's at the wrong site
so that was a protein approach but guess
what every time you have a new protein
you have to you know go through the long
arduous process of making sure that
protein is good it does what it needs to
do and all of that
so we were like how about
targeting molecule into crisper the way
crisper targets is by using a piece of
RNA RNA has bases so it can bind to DNA
which is what you want to do and so
write the irregular system uses RNA take
attaches the enzyme to the RNA and takes
it and makes the edit however RNA binds
to DNA when it when it when it comes to
the correct spot or whatever spot of DNA
it's at however the repulsion between
RNA and DNA is not actually as strong as
a repulsion between DNA and DNA so we
thought if we could add pieces of DNA
into the RNA molecule we could
destabilize the CRISPR system at wrong
sites so it doesn't work don't want to
edit those sites and only keep it stable
the correct sites and that's what we
were able to do and so we're really
excited about this technology going
forward in clinical trials to make a
very safe but still very effective
CRISPR system that was what I did for
the early part of my master's thesis yes
yes and then that that definitely led
you because you're already starting to
work with the Cassadine system then
you're able to really get into more
nitty-gritty off targeting was one thing
so you are solving off targeting exact
huge and then men where'd you move into
absolutely so I was saying there's
really two main limitations of CRISPR
I'm using it for gene editing there
they're quite there are all others but
the two main ones is first the off
targets which I feel like you know the
our lab was able to address we were able
to dress together and then the second
real interesting limitation that you
know I previously said that you know
CRISPR could go to any gene but that's
actually not true I kind of lied about
that Christopher's actually has its own
targeting limitation so say you wanted
to go to a specific DNA sequence right
it's it's you know 20 DNA bases long you
want to go there
right but if you want to go there you
all you need to genes like a CG NT you
need to
jeez the site so if you don't have those
just thing you want to go to a specific
gene you bet you want to specifically
fix but it doesn't have to Jesus so at
the end of the 20 base pairs of DNA
basis and targeting their targeting you
need to G's that for the four CRISPR
cast nine to be able to identify that as
where you want to exactly at it exact
that seems like such a big limitation
rank to what you can do so you can even
do the math in your head right like 1
over 4 to the second is how many times
you would see it to G's 1 over 4 to the
second is 1/16 but if you can actually
go to either because DNA is
double-stranded will literally save if
you go to what 1/8 because you can go to
either strand so you can go to a sea sea
sea or a GG where you can sue with so
with the normal CRISPR cast iron system
you're limited to editing 1/8 of the
human ya know even that's even a little
bit liberal to get like you're giving it
a little bit of flexibility dick but so
it is imperative for us we realize you
know we're not gonna really be able to
use this system if we're restricted by
this limitation why because if you just
want to like disrupt a gene you know if
you just want to like you know you know
get rid of a specific gene your body or
you just want to inserted some somewhere
in the new gene somewhere in the body
you can go anywhere in that gene that
gene is pretty long 10,000 bases long
you're probably going to find two G's
somewhere right but just so you want to
fix an exact spot someone's a mute a
disease is caused by a specific mutation
like sickle cell anemia it's caused by
one specific mutation you want to fix
that specific mutation so if you cannot
go to the that exact spot you know
you're pretty limited so our goal was to
actually expand the range that a crisper
enzyme could go to and you know like our
lab is pretty small right we're like me
and I think you may see no in the
background he's not here right now but
he but he and I you know we were really
intent on finding an enzyme that was
broader you know could go to more places
because
that would enable us to go to and fix a
lot of things we previously couldn't fix
yeah and so and there's thousands of of
diseases that are the single point major
and and the great thing is while we were
doing this there's a new technology that
it was developed called base editing
that could just fix that one thing so
base editing would be really helped by
enzymes that only that can go many
places and so that was our motivation
and you know Rica as as gene added
genome engineers at the Media Lab we're
in a really small we're in a small group
and we're amongst very few people who do
this kind of thing while we're competing
and we have a lot of other people also
trying to do similar stuff but in huge
labs right like sick people sixty
molecular biologists in a lab and so
they're utilizing very you know
large-scale experimental approaches to
find these new enzymes these new tools
that are broader they're more specific
yeah but we know and I are thankfully
computer scientists like you had
mentioned before and so we were able in
firma to bioinformaticians right like we
are really capable of using algorithmic
power you know the computational power
to do the discovery process for us we
could write the code and then allow us
to discover say a new enzyme that could
target more molecules and that's exactly
what we did bad yeah I know that was
pretty fun and like we developed this
cool pipeline called Spamalot and for
those of you who know like the Monty
Python reference I'm going to stop it
right there
anyway we built this really cool
bioinformatics pipe pipeline that
allowed us to say hey hear all the cat
crisper enzymes out there
here are their predicted Pam sequences
this is how many bases they need it's a
target and we were able to identify one
that only needed one gene one G instead
it's two so if you do the math again in
your head one over four now because you
don't you only have four bases and if
you do it on both strands that covers
about 1/2 of
the genome so we were able to find an
enzyme that has affinity towards 1g and
therefore can target about 50% of the
genome and that was I think a big
advancement we were paid a publishing
the sciences open access journal and you
know like published in science is open
access right yeah boom yeah it was it's
like it's somewhere that ever you know
like you know people are now starting to
really use I you know I'm sending this
enzyme out to a lot of people to try it
out you know later button people are
interested in using it because now guess
what you if you're working on a specific
disease if your interest as a geneticist
if you want to study a specific gene you
can do it do so much more broadly
because you can target a lot more
sequences and that is what our
computational pipeline gave us as enzyme
which we then put in right behind you as
we're we're in the lab right now we were
able to go and test it in human cells
that are right in that incubator and
show that this that this enzyme was
brought that this enzyme could target a
lot more sequences than we previously
could target so with your computational
pipeline you're able to identify ways
that genetic engineering can more easily
make the targeting and the cutting more
effective exactly and editing more
effective then this is called SC SC k so
the original cast nine comes from
streptococcus pyogenes bacteria that's
the strep throat bacteria that you have
but we have refound a cassadine that
comes from a similar bacteria that is
that is found in dogs or in the infects
cats and house really animals
it's called streptococcus canis for the
dog for infecting the dog and so that's
where we found this new cast mine and
you know that wasn't even the end of the
story we are able to use this pipeline
to discover another another enzyme that
could go to the other 50% of the genome
we didn't cover the other 50% but we
found one that needed to AIDS all right
so if you could eventually get to one a
right you cover the other 50% right
because you could cover the T and the a
on the both strands but two A's already
gets you to another announcement of the
of
fifty percent which is a really cool I
thought it cool so together two enzymes
that we have in the lab right here you
know I can cover a significant portion
of the genome this so heavily speaks to
the importance of a computational
biology yeah yeah you know that's what
made it possible where there's no way we
were gonna carry out huge experience
first of all we don't have the people to
do it
second of all it's difficult when you're
like not you know you know the CRISPR
lab you know like the big CRISPR labs
are capable of doing these things but we
we have to take our own approaches and
I'm pretty
I'm pretty psyched that we could do it
pretty so effectively in the lab right
here yeah it's it's such an all so it's
it's so visibly pieced together where
it's like this first advancement that
comes about five or so years ago and
then the second wave including
computational biology processing and
figuring out all the bacteria that's
evolved what do these bacteria know as
immune in their immune organizations
that that we don't yet know and how can
we apply that to our lives and so you
get to study all of that and discover
make new discoveries around you we're
basing it off of what nature is giving
us right like they give us a lot of
information if you were doing all of
this from scratch it'd be pretty hard
like you're not we're not as good as
nature and fine-tuning biological
systems right and so we're taking a page
out of nature's playbook and you know
we're we're we're really excited about
what that can even give us going forward
there are a lot of new enzymes and
proteins that have really cool
properties that we're really excited to
exploit in the future and it's also nuts
because this is already now we're not
we're talking because you've found this
you you only need a single gene yeah
half of the genomes available to make
genetic engineering edits to it it it
becomes now a we're not ignorant anymore
now so if we know that we're screening
ourselves like if you are about to have
you have a partner and you're about to
pursue procreating having a child into
the world screen yourself have your
partner screened and
you know better if you are going to pass
along a mutation that's going to cause a
disease correct and then furthermore is
even when it's even when the process
does start of the fertilization of an
embryo that you can still then check
again to make sure that it absolutely
doesn't have the mutation and if it does
have the mutation you'll have full
control of making sure your child does
not have that disease now current and
this is even today for 70% of all of
single point mutation so yeah yeah and
again we can fix those right and that's
what's powerful you know like we have
like first of all you know you have just
a few years ago the lot of these genetic
diseases were incurable and with the
advent of not only this new CRISPR
technologies but base editing right the
ability to flip a single base as I said
before they these technologies together
make it really easy like you said 70% we
can we can target and so when you do get
to that stage where you know you want to
make sure that your offspring doesn't
have a genetic disease you have one of
two options really you you if you think
that the pop if you know that the
offering will have that disease you
could go in with the CRISPR system and
and just design you know an RNA that
targets and the enzyme that goes to that
specific location and make the edit
right after fertilization and then make
sure that the cells were properly edited
the embryos were properly edited and
then re-implant that back into the
mother so you know for a fact that your
child will not have the disease at the
same time a more conservative approach
that still works really well is you
could just you know do in vitro
fertilization and just make sure that
the embryo that you implant doesn't have
the mutation so you have options and you
know there's I don't see a reason why
genetic diseases is going to are gonna
like last for a while because we have
the tools not only to make sure at first
you're go safe but if not go in and
program ibly change what you need to
change and what we're doing here in the
lab is giving you the tools giving you
know the general community the tools to
be able
do that and the beauty of this all is
it's not even just limits to medicine it
slits you can do this in like plants in
in for bio bio fuels you know like like
we're able to even make malaria
mosquitos resistant to malaria by
introducing genes that confer malaria
resistance and into these organisms and
have that reproduce like we're CRISPR
and gene editing has enabled all of
these technologies that will make our
lives better that'll make our technology
safer and you know overall it will
hopefully make society a better place
than it is today but you know it's young
and where we as a me as a CRISPR 2.0
scientist you know it has to make sure
that that we hopefully will get to that
stage yeah yeah there's there's an
interesting sort of like big history
understanding of things where you look
at humans trying to figure out how to
how to do breeding within genetics
yeah and it took so long to get what we
wanted no this is what we wanted you
know like like like even when you just
think just you wanted you're in a
research lab and you work with like mice
okay imagine how long it would take to
get the mice with the exact like what we
call phenotype like kind of like how a
pro an offspring mice that has the
traits you wanted to have to study it'd
take you months but I think you years in
the lab to do this iteratively until you
get a mouse that reproduces well now we
can literally just go into an animal
into a plant into you know one day into
a human and then be able to make the
chain yeah that changes per minute right
yeah that that's what's beautiful about
the system and that's what gives us so
much power at the same time there's
risks and responsibilities that have to
be assessed but we're also that's
something that we also work on and we do
that by educating the people around us
about the system
these uh these risks are and these
ethics and these geopolitics around
these technologies are nuts
it's pretty crazy yeah and it's in
there's a lot of pieces that come into
this puzzle we were you know geopolitics
come into this puzzle we have the
ethical quandary x' that come into this
puzzle what should or shouldn't be
ameliorated as a as a disease there's
the ethics of who is getting the access
to the augmenting technology and that's
not that you know that as as CRISPR
scientist you have a sense of
responsibility to make sure that the
right hands get on it and not only the
right hands are the people who
understand how the system works
unfortunately it's not always how it
worked and I'm sure you know all of you
guys out there you know everyone
probably has heard about the CRISPR baby
scandal that happened in China where a
scientist called hojin kwai was able to
edit the that the embryos of two babies
who are now born Lulu and Nana with
their names and unfortunately this was
our first foray into human embryo
editing right and you know that's that
was not something that we weren't ready
for as CRISPR scientists because we're
we don't feel that you know we've done
all the checks needed to make sure that
CRISPR does exactly what we wanted to do
it all the time and you know that that
that uh you know that kind of like that
apprehension manifested itself where the
edits for these two children were not
expect were not what was needed what
this guy was trying to do was prevent
HIV transmission or pretty much make
these children immune to HIV by editing
their gene they weren't trying to cure a
genetic he wasn't trying to cure a
genetic disease he didn't even like
really prevent them from getting HIV
what he did was essentially gave him an
enhancement of protection of sorts and
not only did he want to do that he also
didn't do it in a very clean fashion you
know like unfortunately the edits to
Lulu and Nana were not exactly what is
needed to make sure that you have HIV
resistance in the future so the point is
that you know like this
the geopolitics as you said are you know
super critical we want to make sure that
it's not getting into the wrong hands
and you know the regulations are there
so that until we're ready to go
you know nothing crazy happens but
because something like this happens you
know what it does is it decreases
sometimes it decreases public trust in
major technology people are scared of it
you know imagine sometimes it also makes
it more easy easily it becomes more in
the public eye which makes it more
receptive so that it's not like Oh what
is this gene interesting but rather you
actually have seen genetic engineering
more in the news and then whether it's a
bad or good thing and you know like I'm
sure you've heard of like the bio hacker
community - they get you know people who
are not like CRISPR scientists they
actually will be able to get their hands
on the CRISPR system and want to do
stuff with it you know hopefully not
injected in themselves I'm sure I think
someone has done that but being able to
use it for their own purposes which is
fine in itself but as long as they know
and they have an understanding of how to
do it and how to do it properly you know
that that is the main ethical question
like at what point do we let people let
this technology run free as the
scientists who are developing the
technology itself so you know it's not
an it's not an answered question but
we're still like figuring ironing out
all of those details and where do the
scientists work with the politicians and
the ethicists and the philosophers and
when are we actually ready because
sometimes when we look at civilization
yeah it's it really doesn't look like
we've advanced our way out of the fifth
grade quite yet the ends of our own
ability to to not get into Wars and to
not pursue conflicts with each other but
rather have that sense of unity we have
to mature as well first correct
yeah and that's I think I feel like I
said before I as those CRISPR scientists
feel a responsibility to educate people
about how CRISPR now gene editing work
that's right it's not gonna just be like
you know this select group of people who
are gonna be using it know it's it one
is gonna come - everything's gonna be
and it's already becoming thousands and
thousands of people soon you're teaching
a class right now yeah it's gonna be
chameleons really fast and it's great to
have those millions because you also
want the creativity out of those
millions exploring it's it's wonderful
because this is one of those
technologies that will use the societal
like collective knowledge to advance
itself
wait up technology affects so many
people you know the input of everyone
comes into view and if that input is an
educated input right if people
understand how the technology works at
its foundation what its applications
could be then we'd have an informed
society and we have one in which the
technology will be used properly and for
the right purposes I'm not going to be
the one who defines that my goal is to
build the technology and then teach it
how to use it to people and that's what
I'm doing actually this this cement this
january teaching CRISPR class here at
MIT teach us about it yeah so like we're
really it's really cool I mean I've
actually explained a lot of what I'm
talking about in the class here today
but but the classes really want a really
a short for four sessions where students
can come in they can learn about how
CRISPR works like the the system
bacterial system then they'll learn
about the mechanism of how it works like
what are the pieces of CRISPR that are
important for you to do gene editing
what are the applications and you can
put it to so that you use gene editing
in the right app in the right ways and
then they'll actually come into this lab
right in here and do CRISPR experiments
this is where they can realize this is a
responsible way of doing science whether
or not they're scientists in a different
field obviously some of them are like
biologists chemists they want to use the
technology for their research but
they're people were like policy a policy
people and you know like students who
are just like there to learn about cool
new things who want who will come in
contact with the technology here in our
lab and do it in a really fun safe
manner too and so they can go out and
you know be able to use it very in a
very in a responsible manner and you
know the final class will talk about
what we were talking about today ethics
right like how how do we together as a
society
face the problem of you know changing
who we are as people
yeah right is that a good thing is that
a bad thing what do you think I want to
hear these opinions everything yeah
overall good thing and definitely it's
the next evolution and we need and we
need to be wanting to get drive
ourselves to the next evolution in a way
that is steering ourselves not off the
cliff exactly more towards the up up the
up the mountain yeah I agree with you
yeah yeah okay I want to ask you what is
going on with your technology next
because you know because you're doing
this computational biology it's opening
up the doors and so many new ways and
you're really excited about that so tell
us more about so we're really interested
in a few questions right like I
especially me as going forward is I
really still want to get to the hundred
percent really like a genomic coverage
we're continually improving our
algorithms we're improving our
experimental techniques so that we are
able to do that hundred percent genomic
coverage that would be cool right like
then you really have free range on where
you can go in the genome and we're close
you know we have two or three enzymes in
our hands that could be great methods to
engineer also we have this computational
tool that can take us and find you know
new enzymes that could be very powerful
so that would be a really critical goal
that we're working on currently a second
goal is definitely to go back to this
idea of base editing right like as you
said before the current set of base
editors can go and fix about what 70% of
all what we call pathogenic simps
mutation single mutations that cause
disease and so it would be wonderful
again to really treat the other you know
a certain number of diseases not only
because it'll fix you know mutations
that cause disease but also gives you a
lot more power as a genome engineer in
whatever application to be able to flip
DNA bases the power of this technology
lies in not having to really make too
much of a change right you don't want to
have to cut a
piece of DNA every single time you want
to make a chain you just want to do a
nice clean chemical transition of a base
just say you won't have a seat
right AC G and T for your DNA just say
you want to go from a C - a - we can do
that already Hobbit and a to achieve we
can do that already and so you know we
have the ability to do these small
changes but when you get to like things
like going from an a to a C or you know
an T to an A that gets it's getting
harder you know we're not it's not as
easy to do all these different based
conversions right now we can do four of
them there's 12 in total right if you do
the math there's 12 DNA based
conversions that you can do so I really
am interested in designing new tools to
be able to do every type of gene of DNA
at it as you can
couple that with this tart expanded
targeting space now you can literally do
whatever genome editing you want to do I
think that would be a great goal for
myself and through my PhD awesome
yes banded targeting and and all base
conversions all base conversions yeah
that would be like you know like you
have a lot of power that's a lot of yeah
totally yeah that's a big moving of the
human knowledge edge for forward yeah I
love that let's see what see this is
moonshots right here this is how you do
moon shots I'm serious to all the young
people you're 24 right I'm actually 26
these 26 problems 26 but when you look
at young people in their mid-20s I'm 26
as well that you've got to have moonshot
goals yeah and you have this moonshot
goal you're hearing it right here
pushing the boundary of knowledge
forward past what is known and doing
things like helping really move the ball
forward with the eradicating disease
making augmentations is so much more
huge huge huge and computational biology
so interesting I love it I want to know
post what are you thinking post what you
want to get done here in the PhD are you
thinking entrepreneur professing you
where are you thinkin it looks really
wonderful about this field is that it's
super open right like you have
everything you build can be very
powerful really like people want to use
it so there's a power in like the IP
that you hold the patents that you have
that you know encompass all the work
we're doing you know it would be really
cool one day to like you know do a
start-up or be an entrepreneur because
you can bring your technologies to a lot
of people at the same time I'm always
interested in solving new problems right
I I'm the person who switched from like
religion to immunology to computer that
molecular by you know like I love
exploring new fields and I think an
academic setting is one of the best
places you can do it I think I'm
naturally build for a place that is you
know free thinking exploring you know
solving cool questions always looking
for the new thing so I you know my whole
tree my whole life was to be a professor
and you know that would be wonderful but
teacher I I don't know about that but
like you really like we can't even
discount like going into like something
like industry because like I said you
remember the OP Devo and Katrina they
don't this big drugs you know that are
gonna cure a lot of people are coming in
industry so you gotta apply what's up
here and what's being done into the
world and so that you get it out out
there and so like you feel a
responsibility to do all of these things
but you can't do all of them you have to
really pick what you want and I think
I'll save that judgment till when I'm
done with the food yeah but you know
like I'm excited I think like hold as
long as you're able to solve cool
questions and do good science like I'm
happy how about we ask you okay so
there's what do you think is the role of
regulation in this being part of the
second wave what do you think yeah it's
it's it's something that you see is very
important but you also realize this very
difficult right like you know that it's
important to be able to make sure that
it gets in the right hands like you said
but at the same time you also want to
make sure that this technology is used
as broadly as possible because you can
you see firsthand when you do your
experiments
what this can be you know what what this
technology can be not like again I'm not
the person who discovered CRISPR I'm the
person who's making it so that it can be
used by other people for really
transformative purposes I am the tool
developer of sorts right like enabler
like I enable people to do it and so you
want people to be enabled you want them
to be empowered to do different
technologies not just for medicine but
agriculture energy you know you know geo
ecological engineering whatever and so
you know like I I want there to be the
ability for people that do good science
and to do good applications I use a good
CRISPR for good applications the same
time I know that you know we like as a
society we collectively need to decide
where to go with this technology even if
I am the one putting in the 18 hours of
work in the lab doing it it's not up to
me you know to say where is my
technology going because it's not going
to just affect me yeah it's gonna affect
you it's gonna affect all everyone out
there you know like we we collectively
bear that burden and so I'm interested
always to hear from you guys you know
people let us know there you know in the
comments below we'd love to hear from
you what do you think about this
technology and you know what can we do
as genome engineers to you know to make
sure that it gets into the right hands
and is used for the right purposes
that's right that's right okay couple
quick questions on the way out that we
like that we like asking our guests what
do you think is a core driving principle
of your life yeah it's it's it's it's to
making to make an impact that will lead
to more impact meaning that I'm here
doing science so that people in the
future will also be able to do good
science so that I'm you know hopefully
will help cure a disease so that those
people who diseases were cured can home
go and make an impact in the world you
know that's me I I am I am one point in
the timeline of humanity but I hope that
time point you know is has enough that
push it keeps pushing humanity forward
because I believe in what we can do and
where what this world can be and you
know being able to do gene editing be
able to need to do maybe even some
in a computer science and you know
understanding in the past with religion
all of these things have contributed to
like understanding people and and giving
them the ability to like make an impact
while you're also making it back to ya
again this is coming you're just like
I'm going to the edge of knowledge and
I'm gonna push the edge so that other
people can build on top of that in the
future that's so beautiful
love it it's fun right you're like I I
have fun every day coming to the lab
people say why do you work like 28 18 20
hours a day I literally work non-stop
because it's fun you know like you got
to love what you do every moment of your
life yes no matter what you do whether
it's talking to you know people about it
by the teaching of class but it's just
doing a random experiment you go running
a control you know like like everything
is contributing yeah you're contributing
to the knowledge of the world and and
that's like I feel very very lucky to be
able to do that alright I have a good
question because you spend so much of
your time understanding the computation
in biology yeah so then you must
understand then how a cell could be
potentially computed all of the function
so yeah so how could all the
civilization evolving on Iraq be
computed so do you think we're in a
simulation I would not I am not gonna
answer that question but I think you're
onto something really really good but
I'll have to sit on think about that
expand more why do you why do you think
you know it's it's computation is so you
know you realize it doesn't come out of
nowhere right like the way life is
forming even CRISPR rate CRISPR is like
such a beautiful thing that nature and
evolution has given to us you think that
there is some ability to understand the
patterns right like there's there is
some programmable elements to how we as
humans
so how society how reality is program
that you're like this is you know it
would make sense for there to be some
alternate explanation for what we're
living
and and you know I'm doing my part to
like understand that small portion of it
but if we one day come to the
understanding this is all just one big
simulation I'm not who am I to say
that's not that's not true you know I'm
all for evidence and you know yeah we're
we're digging into the code of the
simulations is that to figure it all
what are we having right now we're gonna
we're gonna simulate the evolution of a
civilization on a rock just like Earth
orbiting a star and we're gonna fast
forward six millimeter they told this
point to this point here I'd be like
okay yeah okay um and last question that
we like to ask on the show what do you
thinks the most beautiful thing in the
world what's beautiful say oh I don't
know I have to say I I don't know I have
to I have to go with like what I have to
say scent the central dogma of molecular
biology like I just think it's it it's
why we exist you know like I am pretty
practical person you know the central
dogma is like the ability to go from the
DNA to RNA to protein
there's codes for all of life yeah if
that Prop that process is so beautiful
and if and if that doesn't exist we
don't exist nothing exact like our
ability to process all of this doesn't
exist and I know it's a super scientific
answer and it's like no it's great but
that is crazy literally like it every
day I'm in the lab it is and every day I
just live I'm like this is this this is
the central dogma of molecular biology
yet work yeah I love it it's building if
you're so passionate about what you do
that the central dogma of molecular
biology become anything in the world
probably really crazy I love it no
because I'm really crazy too and a lot
of people like us are really crazy in
love with what they are building and
those are the people that are pushing
and pushing the Brinks and the edges so
I love that about you I'm glad that you
answered it that way it's really
beautiful
okay I feel I feel like we did a really
good job yeah he did a really good job
for them this has been such a pleasure
thanks for having me yeah super fun time
feel free to come back if you guys out
there want to know more about the Media
Lab feel free to you know like comment
and I'm happy to like I'm happy to like
see what everyone has to say totes yeah
we got
Sofer for you guys thanks for tuning and
we greatly appreciate you so much we
would love love love for you to comment
below with your thoughts about what we
talked about regarding genetic
engineering and all of the nuance so let
us know what you think also do check out
pronounced links in the bio below also
definitely build go and push the edge of
what's known in our world go to Ill yes
manifest your destiny into the world
everyone join us on patreon links below
because we want to continue supporting
our efforts in going scaling and take
having these conversations shared with
you around the world we love you so much
we'll see you soon peace